situation in southern Israel al jaer as
Charles Stratford is live in stot
Charlie I mean people in the South uh
remain extremely tense with more rocket
attacks and ongoing incidents uh of
infiltration tell us what's been
happening
there well it was a relatively quiet
night in terms of uh rocket fire from
Gaza Darren until about half an hour ago
where we now have reports of a large
barrage abroad it's it's understood
targeting areas in central Israel and
the occupied West Bank we're in stot
which is one of the towns that was
infiltrated by Hamas Palestinian
Fighters actually repeatedly in fact
yesterday there were at least four
incidents in this area where there were
infiltrations that's according to the
Israeli military um we understand that
one of those in incidents involved um in
their words terrorist IST s we call them
Palestinian fighters in vans that were
found near a Kuts close to here we
understand that um an Israeli tank
targeted at least one of those vans and
a number of those Palestinian Fighters
were killed there are also at least two
other incidents in the town of zikim
which as I say is relatively close to
here um at least three Palestinian
Fighters killed in that incident so the
general feeling is that despite these
claims being made by the military that
they have towns like stot under control
close to the Gaza border there are still
these huge concerns about infiltrations
I spoke to the spokesperson for the
Israeli military yesterday and he was
pretty candid he he admitted that they
are struggling and there is still a huge
risk of um Palestinian Fighters getting
through uh so yeah the situation is calm
here but it can change very dramatically
indeed very quickly meanwhile in the
last hour or the mayor of this town the
mayor of stod has been speaking to
Israeli media Israeli TV and he's called
on the government to in his words
effectively flatten Gaza he said that we
have the legitimacy and the strength and
support to go in obviously alluding to a
potential ground Invasion and he said
that's the only way we're going to win
this war okay so yeah all eyes on that
new cabinet um and uh anything could
happen in these areas at any time yeah
and Charlie you've been seeing this huge
mobilization of Israeli troops and armor
near the border how are people there
reacting as they see Israel's military
response
unfold the people are close to the
Border here pretty much anybody you
speak to they want what they call
Revenge um initially of course you can
imagine utter shock to these attacks
anger and of course the trauma continues
but the people still living in these
areas despite advice to evacuate they
basically are banging the drums of war
and it's quite surreal to to to to be in
an amongst them when they visit the
troops they come to these areas handing
out food and drinks in some instances
there are even Vans playing loud music
and you'll get um Israeli civilians
getting out and dancing trying to boost
the morale of the troops so there's this
now this growing underlying feeling of
determination and resolve as I say all
focused potentially if indeed it happens
on some ground Invasion into Gaza all
right Charles statford live for us there
in ashd Charlie thank you